The joe rogan experience.
So let's talk about what we were just talking about it.
You were,
you've wrote a book with a guy about drug dealing and he was going to come on
wearing a mask.
He wanted to come on wearing a Barack Obama mask.
Actually.
Uh,
it's,
it's actually really funny.
The whole story is really fun.
I'm writing this book.
Um,
oh,
I spilled it too.
Um,
it's called the business secrets of drug dealing.
Uh,
you can find it@businesssecretsofdrugdealing.com.
Um,
and I'm serializing it,
uh,
but basically somebody I knew for ages,
um,
in a completely different capacity,
uh,
sort of came out to me last year and said,
um,
you know,
I've been a high level drug dealer for,
for a long time,
basically my whole life.
And wanted to tell a story about,
uh,
you know,
sort of the whole progression of his life,
what kind of drugs,
uh,
only things that grow out of the ground.
So,
uh,
he started off,
um,
this is,
uh,
this is an African American guy.
Uh,
he started off bleeding or not selling mushrooms.
he,
he sort of grew up half in the projects and half an in an upscale suburb.
Uh,
and he in the upscale suburb,
he sold mushrooms,
which she,
uh,
basically got through mail order at a time early in the sort of history of the
Internet when there were some loopholes about things you get spores.
Right?
Yeah.
Well actually you could get the actual really?
Yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
Um,
so he ends up having this whole career.
Uh,
uh,
and he wanted to,
to sort of explain to me what the rules of the game where,
uh,
and do sort of a book version of the 10 Crack Commandments.
Uh,
and so we sat down and,
um,
we couldn't quite figure out how to do it at first,
but we ended up essentially doing a sort of fictionalized version of,
uh,
of his life.
Um,
and the progression is amazing because he,
he goes from being a dealer in all these different parts of the country in
different social spheres.
He's a,
in college,
he deals to rich,
white kids.
He deals on the street and,
and,
and you know,
tough urban neighborhoods.
And then ends up sort of in the legal business,
uh,
in this state,
and lawyer?
No,
no,
no.
He illegal marijuana.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Uh,
and so he's describing that world,
which is not,
um,
there are a lot of misconceptions about it.
Uh,
there,
there are some things about it that are,
um,
not known terribly well.
Like,
you know,
what do you do when you,
uh,
you know,
at a,
at a farm and,
uh,
your crop test dirty,
you know,
with a,
with a contaminant.
Um,
well,
you know,
not everybody just throws it away,
a lot of that stuff ends up,
shipped across country,
goes to other markets.
Uh,
and he sorta describes a lot of this,
like what kind of contaminants would that be?
Like fungal or like a fungus?
Uh,
something like that.
that,
you know,
there are labs that basically have to clear,
uh,
you know,
from what I understand,
um,
that have to clear each of the crops.
And,
uh,
and there are situations where,
you know,
there's a whole bunch of crop and you've got workers that have to be paid.
And what do you do with it?
And the legal market isn't big enough,
um,
to accommodate all of the stuff that's grown.
And so there's sort of still,
you know,
kind of a black market that goes on and he,
he,
he describes this and,
uh,
but even before that,
it's just a fascinating book about,
you know,
all the different things that he learned in the course of his career,
but how to get,
you know,
do the job and not get caught had had a rig,
a load to drive cross country.
How do you do with dummy car?
Um,
you know,
he tells a story about how basically you want four cars,
you want the guy in the front seat to be,
to be,
to look like a drug dealer,
have a terrible record,
drive badly,
uh,
basically to attract the police.
Uh,
and the,
you know,
the third car is the load car,
the second car sort of watching to see if there's,
there's cops in either direction.
And then the fourth car is basically driving up,
uh,
behind the load card is sort of preventing anybody from seeing the license
plate.
And that sort of thing.
And so he just talks about all this stuff and it's,
it's,
it's fascinating.
And,
um,
it was a new kind of writing for me because I'd never really done anything
except straight journalism and we sort of had to do it in narrative form.
And so we're,
we're putting it out serially online right now,
which is really cool.
So you did one of those change the names to protect the innocent.
Exactly,
yeah,
yeah.
Or,
or the guilty.
Yeah.
But for the most part,
based on facts,
yes,
yes.
The situations where let's just say realistic,
you know?
Right.
Yeah.
And,
and his,
you know,
the observations were that,
uh,
that he describes are all,
you know,
things that he actually learned.
The situations were,
you know,
relatively close to things that actually happened.
So,
yeah.
That's interesting.
So that's available now.
Yup.
Again,
it's,
uh,
business secrets of drug dealing.com.
It's kind of a new thing.
Aye.
I,
I grew up,
I'm a huge fan of a serialized,
uh,
detective stories.
I was a big fan of like Dashiell Hammett,
Raymond Chandler,
and I loved a black mask magazine,
which was the big pulp,
new our magazine in the twenties and thirties.
And,
um,
you know,
I grew up reading all those stories and I always,
uh,
it was in the back of my mind always that I wanted to try this a and write a
book,
uh,
on a deadline.
So I'm doing this now.
It's a,
it's basically co-written with this,
uh,
anonymous character who can appear with me on shows like this,
a anywhere because he asks he's,
he's still not captured.
And,
um,
so is there their warrants out for this guy?
No,
he's never been picked up and arrested.
Never been arrested.
No.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's like a smart dude.
He is a smart dude.
He has a smart dude and some of his employers would be very surprised to know
that he's got a hobby like this.
Um,
uh,
it's funny.
Can I,
you know,
I knew him again.
I knew him for years and didn't have the faintest clue,
uh,
that,
that this was,
this was going on.
So keep a job in order to avoid suspicion.
So the,
the book is actually structured with all these rules.
It's chapter has,
has rules.
And at one of his,
his most important rules is always have a job.
Uh,
and he,
it's for a number of reasons.
Number one,
um,
he talks about how when he was young,
he worked at places like,
you know,
a Mariott or Applebee's and he's like,
if you can serve,
um,
have the patients to serve people at an apple bees and not blow up and scream at
people,
then you won't screw up a package like that.
In other words,
if,
if you can have the self discipline to actually get through one of these jobs
and not blow up and be crazy,
then you're going to handle or hindered herself well at a car stop.
That's fascinating.
So he used it almost like as a discipline exercise.
He used it as a discipline exercise.
He learned among other things like,
uh,
another one for his rules,
his dress like an off duty is apple piece waiter,
right?
Like,
do not dress.
Uh,
and he talks about this,
about how most dealers,
um,
they learn their,
their,
uh,
profession,
by watching movies.
You know,
there's no,
there's no book out there.
I mean,
there,
it's not like this generation is growing up reading like near the old iceberg
slam or Donald Goines novels or whatever it is.
They're watching,
you know,
the wire or blow a or Ozar canal or whatever it is.
Um,
but dealers very often dressed like dealers,
you can,
you can kind of spot them,
you know,
and he says,
that's exactly the opposite of what you have to do.
Um,
you know,
where Sperry shoes were boring clothes look like,
you've,
you're on your way to,
to,
you know,
your freshman English class or whatever it is.
Um,
and you know,
[inaudible] sound like a nerdy college kid when,
when,
uh,
the cops pull you over and all that stuff is a,
is sort of central to his,
his whole a worldview about how to avoid getting caught.
Wow.
That would be a great book.
It,
I mean,
it is,
it's,
it's really fun.
And you know,
the,
the fact that,
um,
that the,
you know,
the coauthor is actually a person who's pulling this off makes it,
makes it really interesting and it makes it a real challenge to write it too,
because,
um,
you know,
I had to kind of,
uh,
simulate his voice,
and kind of communicate to people what,
what those situations were like and what things look like from his point of
view.
And obviously I'm white and he's African American and that's,
that's tough.
And,
uh,
but you know,
I think it works,
it's kind of a cool story,
but it must've been a juicy,
like when you found the subject and I just felt like,
oh boy,
we got something here.
Oh yeah.
Super Juicy.
Yeah,
no,
it's,
it's so much fun.
I haven't had this much fun,
like,
fun,
fun writing anything for,
for a long time because,
um,
you know,
most,
most criminal memoirs,
and again,
I grew up a junkie in terms of reading the stuff I love.
I love books that are written after the fact by people who were in crime.
You know,
like pappy alm was one of my favorite books growing up.
I mean,
it's a,
it's an amazing story about not,
not just crime but about prison and what's that like,
but they're always written by people after they got caught.
Right.
And so there's never that book by the person who's still out there,
uh,
and,
and talking about what al La life is like,
um,
successfully,
uh,
still on the other side of the law.
And that,
that part of it is fascinating.
It's just a,
it's a completely new thing.
And,
and he has all these insights that I,
that I would never have thought about.
Like he,
he talks about how,
um,
there's a thing he calls the hood price.
Like if you,
when you're dealing,
uh,
selling to,
um,
uh,
in black neighborhoods even he charges a higher price.
Uh,
because there's more,
there are more problems that you inevitably run into when you're dealing in
those neighborhoods because there was more cops,
which means more lawyers,
which means more security,
which means more attention to detail.
When you deal to the rich white kids does this,
nobody's paying attention,
so you just,
there's less overhead,
you know,
in the business.
Uh,
which is,
which is fascinating.
It's,
it's a,
and you know,
he talks to all about this and,
and he,
he has,
he spent a lifetime kind of just keeping all this stuff in his head,
always wanting to,
to put it down.
And he just got to be too much.
And he just sort of tapped me on the shoulder one day and said,
can we have lunch?
I just want to talk to you about something
before this.
I would say three years.
Wow.
Four years.
Yeah.
That's that easy.
Yeah,
it was,
well,
we had a trust.
You well,
I'm glad we decided to,
did not have him on because he would get busted.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Like you can't,
like if you were on something and you had a mask on,
people go,
that's mad tight.
You know what I mean?
There'd be somebody listening to him.
He doesn't,
maybe he doesn't understand that there's millions of people listening.
I didn't totally agree with you.
It's of those people would go,
that's whatever.
Right.
That's Mike.
That's John.
Whatever his name is,
they would get it.
Even the,
even the Unabomber got caught and he only talked to like two people.
Okay.